ねえ、ここにいるみんなの犬私はあなたの親指
がこのオープンな家の犬を指して
います。彼らは匿名だったので、
このビデオも日本語で英語でやり
ますが、前と同じように
後で日本語をやりましょう。
まず最初
に、前回の親切な言葉をありがとうございまし
た。私が家で仕事をしているので、今の仕事のやり方だけで、なぜ日本に来たのですか？
私の子供が寝ているときだけ、私が
そのビデオをまとめ
て、指の怪我でそれを書くのに非常に長い時間
がかかりました。これは以前よりも改善され、はるかに良くなっていますが、
作るのに非常に長い時間がかかりました ビデオそれは私の娘が生まれてから私が作っ
た最初の種類のより深刻なビデオの1つ
ですので、みんながそれをとても気に入ってくれてとてもうれしいです。
Twitchでストリーミングを開始することを発表する時間
少し
突然ですが、裏話を簡単に説明します
。YouTuberとして、クリエイターとして
、自分の責任者として、私は自分の上司なので
、多様化して倍増することが重要です。
収入が流れるので、Geishaプロジェクトなど
の商品であるパトレオンであるYouTubeです
が、私は実際
に非常に長い間Twitchを調べていました。なぜなら、II
はyoutube.comスラッシュDogenを持っているから
です。
Dogonと私はストリーミングを
開始するかどうかはわかりませんでした
が、twitchは
良いものだと思いました。
そのプラットフォームが本当に
成長しているという理由だけで、twitch commがDogonをスラッシュ
することができれば、それができると思いました。
私のブランド全体に良いことだと思う
ので、私は実際にドメインをドメインに取得しようとしていた
ので、
おそらく約1年前から
、元の所有者に連絡して、彼に
私に ページが、私
がchしようとしたとき アンジュそれは私が待たなければならないと言って、
いくつかの問題があり、それから私
は待ったが、その後私が
それを変更しようと戻ったとき
、
それが私がそれをするつもり
だったのか、 とにかくこの奇妙な問題が
あり、私はそれを得ることができませんでした、そして私は
それを手に入れようとし続けて新しいクリエーターに手を差し伸べました、
そして私は何の牽引力も得ていませんでした、
そして私はTwitchで知っていた私の友人を何人か
試しました
彼に連絡を取りますが、それでも運が悪いので
、約1年後、私はついに
大丈夫だと言いました。私は
このドメイン名を取得する方法を誰かが知っているかどうかをTwitterで実行する
ように依頼します。 ツイートした
ところ、Twitch TVのスラッシュドゴンを取得しようとしています。
すぐに起こったのは、
Twitch Japanの数人のメンバーが直接
メッセージを送ってくれて、
これを設定したいのです
が、基本的には問題でした。 彼ら
が私をフォローしていたので彼らの素晴らしいサポートのために何時間も n Twitterや
YouTubeでも、彼らは私のコンテンツを本当に気に入っていた
ので、とても嬉しかっ
たですが、基本的に
は、ドナードメイン名を取得しようとしていると発表したとき
、これらすべてからこの圧倒的な量のサポートを受けました。
私が予期していなかった人々
がいたので、本質的
に何トンもの人々がストリーミングを開始するつもりだと言っていました
これは素晴らしい
ですあなたがストリーミングを開始するのを見てみたいので
、私の当初の計画はURLを保護することだけでした
そして
、私は今このような注目を集めているので、それ
を利用して
すぐにストリーミングを開始したいと思います。
名前を確保して
から、みんなが忘れてから6か月待っ
てから、本当に良くないからです。
今すぐビジネスのために、
フォロワー全員が来
ているので、ストリーミングを開始するので、明らかに
いくつかのゲームを実行しますが、ゲームは
実行しないので、
一種の日本のレッスンを実行します。 非公式のq
やAのようなものなど、さまざまな
ものがありますが、これらの1つと十分なストリーミング機器を入手したので、このカメラでそれを行うことができ
、Webカメラではなくなります
。  Twitchから始める予定ですが
、これは私の通常のコンテンツのすべてとは非常に異なることを知ってい
ます。多分あなた方の何人
かは、
多分あなた方の多くがそれを言うことにそれほど興味がないのを見て興奮しています
が、少なくとも私は
ここでアナウンスをしたかったので、
私をサポートしてくれた皆さんは、私
がそれをやろうとしていることを知って
いて、このビデオが公開されてからおそらく約1時間後に最初のストリームをやるつもりです。
約3:15
最後のええ約1時間
7月13日土曜日の日本の時間の3:15だと思い
ます。この
発表をするために直前まで待たなければならなかった理由は、私がパトレオンビデオの編集を終えなければならなかったから
です。
約2週間取り組んできました
ob 明らかに私は
すべての常連客のためにその優先順位を最優先にし
なければならないので、それが出るまでこのビデオを延期し
なければなりませんでしたが、興味があれば、今日の最初の公開ストリームの後半から
けいれんを逸脱します。 おそらく1週間ほどで来るでしょう
また私は
ビデオをアップロードする方法を少し変えることを考え
ています今まで私は
これらの日本のレッスンを
2分か3つの別々のような1つのテーマでやっています
テーマは
約2分で結合され
ますが、YouTubeアルゴリズムについては、2週間ごとに
3つの1つの2
分のビデオが2週間の3つのコースで3
つの45秒のビデオよりもはるかに悪いため、あまり良くないと思います。
私
はそれらのビデオをより小さなビデオに分割し始めるかもしれませ
んが、それがアルゴリズムによる影響にどのように影響する
かを確認するためです。
なぜまた日本に来たのか、
それは私にとって非常に重要なビデオ
でした。皆さん
がそれを気に入ってくれて、私の指が良くなっていること
を嬉しく思います。おそらく明らかな
質問は、ゲーム内でどのようにストリーミングするかということだと思います。
これらの奇妙な指の
問題があり、全体として、これらの
2本の指が実際に両手にある
か、最も影響を受けている場合、
私が計画しているゲームで
は、これらが
実際に使用されているとは思わないので、 ここでどのように機能するかを見
ていきますが、それほど問題にはならないと思います
が、先に述べたように、私の
状態は改善しているので、それが
私が得ることができた理由の1つ
です。
でも興味が
あれば
ストリームを見に来て
くれてありがとう
架空のナガは、スキルのホストを呼び出すことができます
より多くのマウンテンホジマン
トリノがマカラナマハに来るので、ヤランの間
に散らばっているオートマトンの聖書ストリーミングまたはロック
はけいれんし
ませんけいれんけいれんテレビスラッシュドゴン彼らは1対1
の愚かな犬では難しいです
彼らはアフマディ異端のロケットであり、
SEOナイマツイッター/犬とマルチ
マシンYouTube/ドゴンもっとアルテミス
ルーシーは余分な糸博士を望んでいます。  Haroun博士の
けいれんTVtwitch.tvスラッシュ犬とそれは
ええ、私はマハカラという名前のセルで小さなパルミテートをした
ので、URLやコックコックコックはありません
コドモバラカ
はマスコットをしなければならないレディキラーコッタです-ハニーそれはソビエト
時代であり、誰かがツイートしてくれます
ホッパー右劇場カタカええ
それは一日中食べられるコアではありませ
んこんにちはハイジマスタースモール 新しいURL車
あなたは神ムハンマドですごめんなさい
JeanieKeikoIran papa KO na mahalだから、
あなたは投資されていますogen-sama Tama see
meThomasmr。 キャラは彼が来たが、
社会のジャナ夫人だった。  yo Kapo
Italyは、恐ろしい
Yatta Yatta sweet ot her car ma yo saga
no CN e Tibetan OTS no yo yo are arrow
choco choco go yeah ahora y mucho mucho
sory Amaya
ahora eater
anata motekokerHajimemañanadecococoesta it is  econ Otto
good I Muhammad a cure sikozu son
Nietzsche nan desu kedo moto e OB
yo no Sanjay sons
jugo fungal Colonies conquer Akhenaten Optimus the PlayStation today re-mose game knows of
software ma ma Thomas mini t Ultima
scimitar Co today Thomas mini like the
you コニーを分類し
ますあなたが知っている津波ケガーキックオフ
うわー私はあなたがテイラーと彼らの経済を知ることができないトップでファッカーではありません
このキャラクターで私が知っている方法ではありません
ゲームサラママ
マリー私が19日目にいるときに来るコーチの夜
私はできませんああ
muymasはマルコトリアではありませんニックン良いです私はT
ガンマトータルチームのためにテストしますあなたはできません
彼はアコースティックゲーム サインこんにちは
あなたにため息をつく必要があります
私は私がありがとうを回したすべてのイラン中田カラが食べるすべてのイラン中田
カラを捕まえた後、私はああ ええ、あなたは
あなたですあなたはすでにあなたが本当にたわごとをしていませんあなた
はあなたの男を手に入れましたあなたはトミー
があなたにそれを手に入れたと思います私はあなたにそれを手に入れ
ました ardはMasseyを知っている必要があります。
複雑なマスター隔離は
自律的ですこんにちはは最古のコンゴトモア
ロスコンエラスムスです